Putin has already attempted to detonate
a nuke was stopped by sabotage Insider
says Russian expert believes senior
level officials are working against
Putin to prevent nuclear detonations in
Ukraine a Moscow Insider has claimed
that Russian President Vladimir Putin
recently attempted to detonate a nuclear
weapon but that his efforts were
sabotaged by top brass at the Kremlin
the report published at the mirror also
says unspecified technical issues could
account for the failure of Russian nukes
in recent weeks unspecified well of
course this could only mean one thing
aliens because that's because that's the
conspiracy theory that whenever you know
like the aliens shut down the news is
that people actually talk about I don't
know I don't know why they think that's
true we I mentioned this briefly before
the show I said I think it absolves
Humanity of responsibility and that's
why people want to believe it the
reality is
yeah I'll put it this way yo world
leaders they're not above you if you sit
down and if you're in a bar you wouldn't
even realize you're talking to someone
because people are just people you go
into the courts you meet politicians you
meet enough people you meet people who
are wealthy and own things and you
realize everybody sort of Acts the exact
same way obviously people know different
things people have access to different
things but what I'm trying to say here
with this is
when you're when your neighbor got angry
at you over some petty BS that same
level of emotion can happen with someone
like Putin who's got his finger over the
button do you think this story is true
Doug I really don't buy it I don't have
any idea what Putin would have to
Advantage himself by detonating a nuke I
mean obviously he's talking on the
defender of Putin actually designed
strategies to defend their allies in
Eastern and Northern Europe against him
I don't want him in the Baltic Nations I
don't want him in Poland Etc but uh he
needs to talk about nukes as a
deterrence against the US and NATO
obviously a red line for him was 2014 of
course when a new government came in it
was Pro West pro-eu Pro NATO we've seen
a similar situation in 2008 of course
with Georgia
uh Georgia was bucking real hard and
working real hard to get NATO membership
and vladder was like Oh no you're not so
he swept in in AB kazia South assessia
in Georgia and waged that that war
achieved his objectives had a buffer
zone and then stopped this I have to say
I'm pleasantly surprised by the actions
of the Ukrainian Armed Forces just who
would have known that they would be able
to stop Vladimir Putin actually have a
counter-offensive yeah well they were
trading since 2014 U.S Special
Operations were down there trading every
single one of them and preparing the
landscape and when you're an invading
Army you don't have the advantage they
have home territory and they have all
the latest and greatest U.S technology
now I actually read this article and
this article is all over the place
number one the mirror doesn't have the
best reputation and they say in the
article quote Insider claims the launch
was uh was was not done because of
technical failure or by reluctant
military Chiefs so again who's the
source who's telling you these stories
and and number two you can't even get
the story correct which one is it the
mirrorism certified Luke so yeah it says
it's good and another thing to
understand here there is a chain of
command specifically with Russia when it
comes to launching nuclear weapons that
people should know about because it's
not just Vladimir Putin pressing his
finger on the button uh he also uh in in
Russia they also have something that's
sort of similar like the nuclear
football but they have a briefcase that
essentially notifies the general staff
the general staff have access to the
launch codes then after the general
staff get the launch codes they could
give it to individual weapons commanders
then they of course execute the
procedure then they send the nuke so
that's the protocol that's the chain of
command that they have in Russia which I
think is is also important to understand
here it's not just one guy pressing the
button and there are ways that the chain
of command the general staff or the
individual commanders could say no this
is crazy and and that's a likely
scenario here okay but how about this
Putin leaked the story on purpose to
scare people in the west to think that
he's actively prepared and wants to use
nukes you know what I mean like saber
rattle to the extreme there is Merit to
that we listen to any of his majors
speeches and usually something about
nukes comes up or through a proxy of his
and so yes that's his deterrent model
much as Saddam Hussein you know I was
part of the Desert Storm Liberty in
Kuwait you know a war for energy by the
way and we knew that
but then Saddam Hussein got rid of his
chemical biological weapons didn't tell
the west but he kept talking about he's
going to use him against us as a
deterrent so I do believe that that's a
possibility Putin wants us to know that
if we take it to the next level there's
a high danger that it's going to
escalate what what do you think uh you
know I'm not asking because I haven't
read a lot about this or that the
audience doesn't have an idea but I'm
curious your thoughts why do you think
Putin decided to invade Ukraine and why
is this happening
blender Putin has a bunch of problems on
his hands first off he's a single
commodity country basically it's oil and
gas a few years ago with seven 70
billion dollars a year now it's over 100
billion sanks of the gas prices
um a couple issues though Ukraine has
been drawing closer and closer to the EU
and NATO and the United States the
government is very Pro since 2014.
when most of these troubles began he
also has a population problem in that
his demographics are shrinking as far as
ethnic European Russians I'm not talking
about the Asians that make up most of
his country and and that demographic he
would like to have them in my studies
within a sphere of influence I think the
most vulnerable place in Europe other
than Ukraine is a Eastern labia dagger
pills when I visited there some years
ago I did not feel safe and I was there
in civilian clothes with a Danish buddy
of mine and uh it's like 90 ethnic
Russian and most of the Russians there
stayed as as a result of the Cold War
being stationed there their former their
dads were military members or Intel
officials and they're receiving a
stipend from Moscow by the way as well
about up to a thousand dollars a month
to live the Russian citizens they're
there the latvians who are ethnic Russia
yeah things don't look very promising
for the Russian Empire and population
decline is another major factor and now
with this war that that only has been
exacerbated that much uh worse it's a
Petro State Ukraine is also going to
challenge them specifically with the
national research sources that they have
the gas that they have specifically in
the regions that Vladimir Putin now is
occupying inside of Ukraine so there's a
lot of things happening behind the
scenes there's of course NATO and their
influence and them being on their border
there's of course the sphere of
influence that Russia wants to still
maintain in this specific region and
it's a back and forth Challenge and I
think it was a desperate move as a
desperate situation and it's it's it's
it's a crazy situation that's only going
to get crazier from here and he needed a
decisive knockout blown that first week
and when when the Russian aerosol and
Airborne units came into the airport
outside of Kiev those were those are
Putin's best forces there's two armies
in Russia that I call you have to
specially trained highly motivated ones
like the Airborne Special Forces of air
assault and then you have the rest and
the rest right now you're seeing being
grinded down by the ukrainians when they
were beaten back that was a clear sign
that Putin was in trouble this would be
a long protractor yeah I remember seeing
that seeing them land in the airport
inside of Kiev and then not hearing
anything else about them because they
weren't nowhere to be found and I'm like
that doesn't really make sense this
looks like a
it's about buffer States you probably
look you said it it's a buffer because
Napoleon and the Germans and two Wars
and what have you when um when the first
attempt to go into grozny in the
caucuses and the Russians are beaten
back and eventually came back with
overwhelming force and I don't think
Putin has that leeway though right now
do you think it's reasonable uh in the
in the sense of an Armistice for Eastern
Ukraine to be split between the
ukrainians and the Russians those
freeways that go into Crimea I think
that's ultimately the goal is to take
those freeways to turn Crimea into it
and Sebastopol into a trade Hub but do
you think that's reasonable for Ukraine
and Russia to share those freeways to
each take one and then or neutralize the
territory in some sense are you saying
like the Eastern region goes to Russia
or make it neutral or or that just the
freeway from the Don bass there's two of
them and one of them could be Ukrainian
one of them could be Russia
so the land bridge that you're
describing again is exactly what
Vladimir Putin needed and I think
actually his idea that driving that land
bridge East I'm sorry West towards uh
the transnistra which is a breakaway
Republican on the Ukrainian Romanian
borders I think he wants to have a a
broader pro-russian area underneath his
grass it does remind me a bit analogies
historically are dangerous but sedate
and land 1938
Czechoslovakia Germans there in
Czechoslovakia and of course I'm gonna
go in and the bad guy Hitler goes in and
liberates liberates quote unquote and
we're seeing a similar thing but the
problem with Putin has is the resolve of
the West I mean how many billions of
dollars of American money has gone in
there at least a hundred on the books I
mean well there's secret budgets and
then there's public budgets the public
budget is around 60 to 80 to 100 people
guesstimate right now but the the house
right now is talking about doing another
60 billion uh Bill specifically just for
Ukraine that's a lot of money and you
think about the Germans are so proud
because they came out and they announced
they're giving two billion dollars to
the UK Iranians to fight the Russians
but the Dirty Little Secret is is
they're paying two billion dollars a
month for Russian oil and gas the
hypocrisy you know when Trump in 20
remember in 2018 in the U.N Trump gave a
speech and lectured the Germans about
real life and they they were laughing at
him and mocking him who's laughing now
yeah yeah not the uh working class in
this country who are looking at their
gas tanks going we we hit what was it
five something a gallon it went down now
it's going back up California it's eight
bucks in some parts for the Germans who
are told prepare not to take hot showers
this winter because of energy costs did
you hear this the BBC is preparing
scripts for when they have to announce
the blackouts in the UK that was that
was the guardian we talked about that
the other day do you see any resolution
to this because all I'm seeing is
escalation escalation obviously the
winter is going to stop a lot of the
fighting but Putin is kind of posturing
like he might uh launch another Invasion
from the north of Belarus right now uh
all I see is escalations do you see any
way that this could possibly de-escalate
I know Putin said he's open to
negotiations during the upcoming G20
meeting do you think that's going to be
successful I viewed a Russian broadcast
last night that was talking about how
there's going to be no operations this
winter I think there probably will be
but it'll be minor I see no off-ramp
this year yeah what do you think an
off-ramp would look like a negotiated
piece um but it's going to have to be
the United States this is a hard thing
to say do you tell Ukraine to give up
you know Ukrainian territory you know
what the sad thing is and well is it sad
I don't know the 1994 the Bucharest
treaty remember that that Ukraine was
like the third largest nuclear power in
the world at the time that's right and
and the United States Russia and Great
Britain Province the defender borders if
they'd give up the nukes and they gave
up the nukes and who's defending their
borders that's the problem we have and
Russia promised not to invade them if
they gave the nukes and then and then
here we are and the problem with this is
it sends a signal to every country build
nukes as fast as possible or else
exactly that's that's nightmarish that's
what the uh the Indian general staff
after the desert storm in 1991 and that
was my first combat experience there
they did a study in 92 saying we have to
get nukes to prevent this kind of attack
on us from any country not specifically
the United States
they're the Bread Basket of Europe
they're you know and they have a long
tumultuous history they're I called them
the Afghanistan of Europe because when
you look at all the violence all the
bloodsheds specifically in Ukraine it is
a major Clash point and people were
kidding themselves not to see this as an
upcoming major proxy war that's
happening right now and you know I I
could only hope it de-escalates but I
think this could even last a decade I
think it could even last more than that
especially with the way that these wars
are fought especially with how close the
people are especially how there's
there's neighbors fighting against each
other which is atrocious which is
absolutely horrible I think we should
try to stop it but but at the same time
I don't see it stopping anytime soon
you'd have to Ukraine would have to
sacrifice the Eastern region they'd have
to give that up it's unless you know
Putin just eventually gives up but I
think Putin Canon will use nukes I'll be
at I don't have nearly the military
expertise you do uh Senator but my
concern is that Putin is he's
ideological and he's um
he's looking at the end of the great
Russian Empire of what Russia is I don't
I don't see him just eventually going
like well you know we lost this one I
think he looks at it like we will be
great we will never back down under no
circumstances if he loses in Ukraine
he's done right and you know you hear
Rumblings now I don't think it's is as
viable as Western you know comment
commentators are saying because he's
been very successful in eliminating
opposition around him the past you know
two decades actually he's actually the
longest uh ruler since is ours at this
point here I mean it's incredible uh
Ukraine I mean wow if they can push
through this winter here and then have
time to re-arm and refit and retrain
with all this new equipment and this
money hopefully that's going through the
battlefield I mean they might be able to
start putting the Russians back but yeah
and then what do you do Vladimir Putin
when your armies are pushed out and that
might happen or buy a small one I mean
can they afford to buy eastern Ukraine
is it cost them 300 billion dollars
well this is why the Chinese have a
weird kind of situation on their hands
here because they they're a big trading
partner with Ukraine they have a lot of
relations with Ukraine but at the same
time they're still geopolitically
opposed against the United States so
this is a very weird situation for them
they're kind of like one foot in one
foot out but I think they're also a
country that we should be looking at
right now especially when it comes to
Taiwan especially when it comes to the
bigger geopolitical picture especially
with bricks and the petrodollar in
question with Saudi Arabia thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there